[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo ici au
parlement européen à bruxelles dans
cette édition nous irons de l'autre côté
des alpes en italie berceau du mouvement
5 étoiles qui a obtenu plus de 30% des
suffrages aux dernières élections
législatives
né d'un rassemblement anti élites et
anti corruption au milieu des années
2000 le mouvement est devenu en moins de
dix ans la première formation politique
du pays peut-on le comparer au gilet
jaune en france nous en discuterons avec
nos trois invités
autre question au programme le moteur
franco allemand fonctionne t-il toujours
à plein régime
nous reviendrons sur la signature du
traité d'aix la chapelle par angela
merkel et emmanuel macron le 22 janvier
mais d'abord zoom sur le brésil qui a
connu un nouvel épisode à la chambre des
communes avec le vote de cet amendement
donnant à theresa may mandat pour
renégocier l'accord on les écoute il est
maintenant clair qu'il existe une voie
qui peut garantir une majorité
substantielle et durable au sein de
cette assemblée pour quitter l'union
européenne avec un accord nous allons
maintenant faire avancer ce mandat et
cherchait à obtenir des changements
juridiquement contraignant à l'accord du
retrait et pour en discuter
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce
plateau andreas fable bonjour vous êtes
allemands membres de la cd ou en
allemagne et du parti populaire européen
dans ce parlement européen leur theresa
may 1 qui souhaitent revenir à bruxelles
pour négocier renégocier l'accord sur le
brésil mais à la face à elle des
européens qui ont dit que cet accord
n'était pas renégociable est-ce qu'on
entre finalement dans un dialogue de
sourds on se trouve depuis des mois dans
un dialogue de sourds
mais c'est un dialogue avec des gens qui
comprennent qu'ils ne sont pas sourds
mais que le vote britannique les a mis
dans cette situation donc il faut
trouver une solution de compromis qui
n'est pas vraiment un changement de fond
et il faut juste espérer qu'on peut
trouver une telle chose car ça serait
dommage que tout le travail que michel
barnier a investi seraient annulés à un
certain moment donné il n'y a pas de
changement de fond possible comme le
souhaiterait theresa may non il n'ya pas
de ya pas de changement de faux possible
alors on va revenir maintenant sur un
sujet qui vous concerne directement les
relations entre les deux rives du rhin
avec cette signature le 22 janvier par
angela merkel et emmanuel macron du
traité franco allemand sans ambition
pour certains entérinant un abandon de
souveraineté par la france pour d'autres
aurélie d'afas nous détaille les grandes
lignes de son contenu
[Musique]
55 ans après le traité de l'élysée acte
fondateur de l'amitié franco allemande
angela merkel et emmanuel macron se sont
retrouvés à aix-la-chapelle pour écrire
une nouvelle page de l'histoire des deux
pays
objectif affiché renforcer la
coopération et approfondir les modalités
du traité initial notamment dans le
domaine de la défense
le nouveau traité d'aix la chapelle
instaure un conseil franco allemand de
défense et de sécurité
il prévoit également une clause de
solidarité binational chaque pays
s'engage ainsi à prêter aide et
assistance en cas d'agression contre le
territoire du voisin les deux dirigeants
ont à cette occasion réaffirmé leur
volonté de faire naître une armée
européenne dans le domaine de la
diplomatie l'obtention pour l'allemagne
d'un siège de membre permanent au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu devient une
priorité
autres objectifs du traité renforcer les
relations dans les régions
transfrontalières faciliter les
démarches pour les entreprises et les
citoyens et favoriser l'apprentissage de
la langue
enfin les deux pays affichent leur
volonté de rapprochement sur la
transition énergétique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on le voit un andreas frappe de
grands objectifs sont affichés dans ce
traité mais il est signé un moment très
particulier pour les deux dirigeants
emmanuel macron qui est affaibli dans
son pays par la crise des gilet jaune et
angela merkel dont on sait qu'elle va
quitter son poste en 2021
qu'en est-il vraiment selon vous du
couple franco-allemand du moteur franco
allemand
c'est vrai que ça a pris un peu de temps
pour emmanuel macron et surtout pour un
gala merck de trouver ce mode de trouver
un ancrage diplomatique et officielle
pourrait affirmer cette coopération la
plus intense en europe et c'est pour ça
que je trouve c'est un signal très fort
surtout comme je viens d'une zone
transfrontalière ou les gens dans les
zones de fois entre transfrontalières
sont les dernières à comprendre que
l'europe est une bonne chose mais que
l'europe ne fonctionne pas encore assez
bien et souvent à paris à berne assez
sous-estimé mais légende qui naviguent
du jour à l'autre dans de l'ain pays à
l'autre ils comprennent qu'on n'est pas
encore arrivé à ce rêve de que l'europe
fonctionne assez bien
donc les buts ce traité sont absolument
positif
l'idée que les deux parlements doivent
traiter les questions européennes
ensemble c'est bien car l'europe de la
subsidiarité ça commence avec les
parlements nationaux
et si on peut s'accorder mieux là c'est
très positif donc moi je trouve c'est
une très bonne chose elle ne changera
pas beaucoup sur le fond mais elle
changera beaucoup sur le mode de la
coopération et c'est très positif
alors j'aurais comparé notamment de
cette clause de défense mutuelle ans est
un sujet sur lequel est bien les deux
pays n'ont pas toujours été d'accord est
ce qu'on peut parler avec ce traité des
prémices d'une armée européenne comme le
voudrait la france je pense à l'enjeu
principal a été toujours que les
allemands étaient très réticents
vis-à-vis le nucléaire que les allemands
dans ce traité accepte que les français
ont le nucléaire et que c'est une bonne
chose aussi pour nous c'est un grand pas
en arrière en avant excusez moi un grand
pas en avant et je pense que trump et
d'autres ont probablement beaucoup aidé
à aux allemands à comprendre que qu'on a
besoin de cette force des français et
que nous nous défendons ensemble c'est
pas une nouveauté c'est déjà clair pour
les militaires depuis longtemps
qu'on l'a fait en comme ça c'est
peut-être quelque chose de nouveau mais
de très positif car les gens viennent
mieux comprendre qu'il faut encore plus
fortement qu'au près alors je le disais
en introduction à ce traité a vivement
fait réagir les extrêmes droites en
allemagne comme en france la présidente
du rassemblement national a
immédiatement dénoncé un abandon de
souveraineté par la france si une
véritable trahison de la france
une de plus un vraiment emmanuel macron
est en train de vendre notre pays à la
découpe et il est en train de défendre
et notre souveraineté
il va à aix la chapelle en réalité
détruire ce que le général de gaulle
avait fait c'est à dire mener la france
en première division en quelque sorte un
un pays avec une puissance telle qu'elle
discute avec toutes les grandes nations
du monde
alors le son cloche ans il est à peu
près le même pour l'afd en allemagne est
ce que à quatre mois des élections
européennes et bien ce traité peut
vraiment aider à lutter contre la montée
des nationalismes selon vous bon je
pense il ya tellement deux arguments
fausses et faut qu'on ne peux pas
vraiment répondre à tous je pense
évident que cela n'a rien à voir avec la
souverainté mais c'est vrai que la
globalisation de la mondialisation a
changé le monde et donc il faut trouver
des réponses
et si on peut donner une réponse commune
elle sera toujours meilleur que des
réponses nationales etc la plupart des
gens en france et en allemagne et qui le
comprennent
il va pas toujours y avoir quelqu'un à
qui ne veulent pas le comprendre mais on
ne doit pas ce vraiment concentré sur il
faut trouver des solutions au long terme
et on le voit avec monsieur on le voit
avec d'autres si on est unis en europe
on est plus fort que deux seuls et c'est
un peu ce message que le trad le traité
veut aussi communiquer c'est ce que je
pense est vrai alors ce traité il scelle
également une volonté de renforcer la
coopération industrielle entre
l'allemagne et la france on attend
d'ailleurs un courant février la
décision de la commission européenne qui
dira si elle autorise le projet de
fusion d'alstom et de siemens bruxelles
craint une position trop dominante
voyez ce qu'on dit le ministre français
de l'économie l'europe et la commission
européenne doit changer d'attitude dans
les décisions qu'elles prennent
prenez l'exemple du ferroviaire et de la
fusion entre siemens et alstom
vous avez un géant chinois qui a émergé
en 15 ans et nous on continuerait à
appliquer des règles qui date du 20e
siècle
alstom et siemens viennent de faire de
nouvelles concessions à la commission
européenne pour réaliser cette fusion
entre alstom et siemens et créer un
champion européen du ferroviaire plus
rien je dis bien plus rien ne justifie
aujourd'hui un refus par la commission
européenne de la fusion entre siemens et
alstom
alors ce projet de fusion il est
symbolique justement après la signature
la signature de ce traité
franco-allemand c'est vrai c'est vrai et
pur pour cette raison j'ai toujours dit
que les deux entreprises doit faire tout
pour être pour avoir du succès pour
cette fusion est apparemment ils n'ont
pas fait tout ce que voulait la
commissaire madame vestiaires c'est
regrettable car c'est vraiment important
que nous essayons de mettre ensemble les
forces en europe pour mieux être en
concurrence internationale
mais de l'autre côté il faut aussi faire
en sorte que les petits pays en europe
qui doivent aussi apprendre à prendre et
trouver des solutions pour leur marché
du ferroviaire que eux ils ne sont pas
avec c'est donc là et quelquefois il ya
un petit travail de deux d'acceptation
qui n'est pas toujours fait parfaitement
malheureusement je ne vois pas comment
on va sortir dans le sens de cette
impasse en ce moment merci beaucoup
embrayage faible d'être venu aujourd'hui
nous éclairer sur ses relations franco
allemandes qui sont essentiels à la
construction européenne nous prenons
maintenant la direction de l'italie
dirigé depuis huit mois par une
improbable coalition formée d'un côté
par la ligue parti d'extrême droite de
matteo salvini et de l'autre par le
mouvement 5 étoiles un parti anti
système
dirigée par luigi di maio je vous
propose aujourd'hui de nous attarder sur
le fonctionnement de cette deuxième
formation politique née d'un mouvement
de mécontentement populaire au milieu
des années 2000 un parti aujourd'hui
basé sur le principe de démocratie
directe
voyez ce reportage au coeur de la
galaxie 5 étoiles il est signé ces
styles siksou
[Musique]
il a le costume et latitude mais ricardo
fera caro a dû apprendre vite ce tout
jeune ministre italien était encore il
ya cinq ans juriste dans une entreprise
d'énergie
une ascension rapide persuadé qu'il faut
redonner la parole au peuple
il participe aux manifestations
citoyennes lancé dès 2009 par le
mouvement 5 étoiles aujourd'hui il est
chargé de la démocratie directe du
gouvernement formé par giuseppe compter
ses limites à la participation
ce n'est plus possible aujourd'hui de
limiter la participation des citoyens au
vote tous les cinq ans avec une croix
sur une feuille
ceci a créé avec le temps des distances
les citoyens veulent prendre part au
débat politique
donc si on s'enferme dans les palais et
qu'on décide à la place des citoyens
sans qu'ils puissent contrôler avec des
instruments institutionnels
ce que font leurs représentants ont créé
la confrontation entre le peuple et le
pouvoir
c'est destructeur n'est pas constructif
elles sont non seulement été destructive
propose été portée par les succès
électoraux fulgurant de son mouvement
ricardo près caro est devenu l'un des
visages prometteur des cinq étoiles un
des huit ministres du mouvement sur les
18 du gouvernement de coalition
ce renouvellement politique a été
possible car très vite le mouvement cinq
étoiles a fait le choix de se structurer
et à présenter des candidats aux
élections
l'autre élément du succès c'est cet
homme
beppe grillo le fondateur du mouvement
et sa promesse balayé la classe
politique traditionnelle dès 2009 cet
humoriste italien reconverti en leader
politique attire les foules mais surtout
les électeurs avec son discours anti
système assez proche de celui
aujourd'hui des gilet jaune de la
leadership des grilles là était
fondamental 7,7 au leadership très très
étrange ce n'est pas un véritable leader
politique n'est pas lui ils ne prennent
véritablement pas des décisions
il est plus une catalysateur je pense a
été la figure de gril pendant qu'il n'y
a pas d catalysateur parmi les régions
et sa ceinture réseau je pense parce que
le moment cinq étoiles est devenu un
véritable mouvement politique
pendant que les gie les gens ne sont pas
ça
le mouvement 5 étoiles un mouvement né
sur internet pas dans la rue ni sur les
ronds-points alessio est un petit
commerçant est lui dans la banlieue de
rome
il y a quatre ans confronté à la maladie
de son père il découvre un système de
santé défaillant et décide de s'engager
dans le moment cinq étoiles il que
depuis participé activement à la
politique de son pays
grâce au site internet des cinq étoiles
la plateforme rousseau alors voilà je me
connecte sur le site depuis quatre ans
il donne des avis aux parlementaires de
son mouvement sur les loi en examen au
parlement
il choisit les candidats aux élections
partage avec les autres militants les
bonnes pratiques et peut même proposer
des lois quand il met un rapport j'ai
envoyé une proposition de loi s'agit
d'un contrat de travail qui indemnise la
maternité dans les petites entreprises
segura mais dans ce cas le démon gras à
l'ego c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui j'ai un
instrument démocratique à disposition je
ne dois pas aller dans le bureau d'une
mairie ou d'un ministère où je ne serai
pas comment faire bouger des choses ni à
qui m'adresser
aujourd'hui je peux à partir de chez moi
proposer des lois qui naissent de ma
propre expérience de vie
un outil révolutionnaire de démocratie
finalement peu utilisé le site contre et
dix mille inscrits loin du nombre
d'électeurs du mouvement estimé à 10
millions il est par ailleurs accusé d'un
manque de transparence selon ce
journaliste qui a enquêté sur la
plateforme rousseau qui contrôle la
tonne système ad l'offshore celui qui
contrôle le système rousseau a
potentiellement accès à tout
l'historique de tous les votes de tous
les inscrits et risque le risque c'est
que cette plateforme que l'on présente
comme un grand exemple de démocratie
directe pourrait en réalité contrôler
les votes des inscrits ont voté une
plateforme rousseau en tout cas proposé
au gilet jaune par le vice président du
conseil issu du mouvement 5 étoiles
luigi di maio qui tentent des
rapprochements à quelques mois des
élections européennes d'or en ce moment
on est ouvert au dialogue avec tous les
nouveaux mouvements qui sont en train de
naître en europe
luigi di maio on a déjà rencontré
quelques-uns on est en train de
construire un nouveau groupe européen
basé sur la démocratie directe
les gilet jaune vont ils suivre le
chemin de leurs cousins italiens
pas si sûr aux prochaines élections
européennes
plusieurs listes ont été déposées et
elles sont déjà contestées
[Musique]
et pour en discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau lauragais à
bonjour bonjour bravo vous êtes
italienne justement membre du mouvement
5 étoiles affiliés dans ce parlement
européen au groupe europe de la liberté
et de la démocratie directe face à vous
aujourd'hui jean arthuis bonjour bonjour
vous êtes français vous avez rejoint la
république en marche et vous appartenait
au groupe des démocrates et libéraux
dans ce parlement européen et pour
compléter ce plateau j'ai le plaisir de
recevoir aujourd'hui lucato mini bonjour
bonjour vous êtes professeur à
l'université libre de bruxelles et vous
intéresser particulièrement à l'avenir
des démocraties
alors on l'a vu dans ce reportage
lauragais à ce ministre qui a dû
apprendre très vite ce métier d'homme
politique j'imagine que c'était aussi
votre cas vous avez été élu dans ce
parlement européen en 2014 alors
finalement comment est ce qu'on endosse
les habits d'une eurodéputée comme on
vient comme vous d'un mouvement comme le
mouvement 5 étoiles qui finalement ne
répond pas aux critères classiques un de
la politique
en fait pour le moment cinq étoiles les
politiciens c'est pas un vestiaire c'est
pas juste dans la traditionnelle idée
qui on a de la politique nous sommes et
nous resterons des citoyens qui ont
prêté sa vie pour un temps bien définis
à la priorité citoyenne dans ce
parlement
bien sûr en fait elle les porte parole
du mouvement que cinq étoiles on a eu
règles bien définies
on peut faire juste des mandats et puis
y retourner chercher à faire la vie
normale j'ai un travail en italie j'ai
ma fille et quand mon expérience
politique sera terminé j'ai retourné
rama chez moi à faire ma vie est
aujourd'hui même
luigi di maio il est très jeune en fait
mais il a démontré en fait un peu du
temple d'être en grands leaders
politiques
il a fait des choses lui il est évident
politique assez rapidement oui mais l'a
démontré dette d'avoir des dot de
leadership très forte très importante
en fait en p2 - et là il a fait des
choses très concrètes en italie avait
le gouvernement de mohamed 5 étoiles je
crois qu'ils en europe
on n'a pas un politicien qui comme luigi
di maio 1p du temple a fait des choses
très fort très important alors c'est
très concret un bon citoyen qu'il a
trouvé un leader jean arthuis on peut
difficilement ne pas penser évidemment
en voyant ce reportage en voyant la
genèse du mouvement 5 étoiles aux
mouvements des gilet jaune en france
est-ce que selon vous ce mouvement est
bien pourrait connaître le même succès
finalement que mouvement 5 étoiles je
pense que la colère qu'exprime le gilet
jaune vient de loin déjà en 1995 jacques
chirac candidat à la présidence de la
république française partait d'un
constat de deux fractures sociales
donc ceci vient de loin nombre de
personnes de familles sont aujourd'hui
en difficulté pendant des années chacun
qu'il fût pauvres ou riches avaient le
sentiment que demain serait mieux
qu'aujourd'hui et que les enfants
auraient en sort encore plus enviable ce
qui a fonctionné pendant un certains
nombre de décennies et c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui depuis depuis
une trentaine d'années la croissance
n'est plus au même niveau pour parler
des livres donc des racines de ce
mécontentement luca toni niveau qui
connaissait très bien ces mouvements
quels sont les éventuels points communs
et des différences entre les gilet jaune
en france et le mouvement 5 étoiles en
italie c'est donc c'est un jeu c'est un
jeu très risqué je vous le dis de faire
cette comparaison mais on peut jouer le
jeu notamment sur le fonctionnement
commencé dans le fonctionnement des deux
mondes il ya deux aspects sur
l'organisation le fonctionnement il ya
deux aspects qui sont très très
différents entre les deux les gilets
jaunes sont un mouvement qui aucun
régime d'une mobilisation spontanée
ça c'est clair c'est évident que mon ya
pas de leader il n'y a pas
d'organisation car ce serait la grosse
différence c'est la faisant différence
tandis que le mouvement 5 étoiles dès le
début 2007 2009 via vb il y avait déjà
bp cris l'annoncé là c'est le leader et
que dès le début
il ya un autre aspect parfois on pense à
internet
on pense à web comme outil de
mobilisation de participation et alors
là c'est clair que pour le pour les j
les jeux je pense que internet reste
encore les réseaux sociaux reste encore
un outil très important pour mobiliser
pour se mobiliser pour manifester tandis
que si on regarde l'histoire du
mouvement 5 étoiles internet le blog le
blog de beppe grillo tout ça a été
utilisée comme un outil pour créer le
consensus
et il ya la différence dans le mouvement
5 étoiles cette plateforme rousseau un
convoi dans le reportage 1 cette
plateforme rousseau qui permet aux
adhérents finalement de voter mais elle
est aussi accusée d'être très opaque un
d'ailleurs et bien 68 % des membres du
mouvement 5 étoiles il participait en
2013 ils n'étaient plus que 13 % en 2017
elle est décrite comme un exemple de
démocratie directe mais finalement le
ragga et ce qu'elle fonctionne aussi
bien que ça mais en fait si vous me
parlez d'opacité je vais vous poser une
question très facile très simple je vais
vous demander si vous avez jamais prouvé
à vous inscrire dans la plateforme rosso
c'est la chose plus facile dans le web
vous pouvez vous inscrire participer
votez tous les citoyens qui veulent
prouver à ses inscrire participer voter
et si beau mais parler de chiffres moi
aussi je dois répondre avec des si
facilité de s'inscrire mais on accuse
cette plate forme parfois des
propositions qui sont faites par les
citoyens seraient effacées c'est ce qui
ressort des enquêtes oui mais certains
journalistes donc mais je vais vous
répondre avec les chiffres parce que
dans 2018
on a voté par reçu les citoyennes on
appelait à voter dans cinq fois on a
choisi par la plateforme rousseau 329
citoyenne qu'aujourd'hui elles sont
élues dans les parlements italienne dans
les saynètes dans la chambre des députés
et
sont élus par la plateforme ressources
en eau mais moi aussi en 2014 je suis
choisi par la plateforme est reçu et je
suis arrivé ici dans les parlements
européenne on a choisi on a discuté on a
voté le programme politique qui
aujourd'hui c'est les programmes des
gouvernements de mouvement que cinq
étoiles en italie on a choisi les chefs
politiques luigi di maio par la
plateforme rosso est alors je ne crois
pas qu'ils en europe
il y a un an partis politiques
mouvements politiques ouvertes comme les
mouvements 5 étoiles qui utilisent la
démocratie directe comme nous alors
selon vous c'est un outil efficace 1 est
en tout cas cette plateforme est bien l
inspire certains gilet jaune qui ont
décidé de lancer leur propre plateforme
regarder on a réussi à démarrer en paca
une plate forme lorsque vous la faire
voir voilà donc comment ça se voit
l'envers s'appelle paca point plateforme
gilet jaune point fr on a lancé ça et on
a commencé les consultations il faut
savoir qu'on est plusieurs régions en
ski avons dansé le même outil
donc on ambiance avec toulouse avec
l'aquitaine a et c'est avec la bretagne
et et puis il ya des gens il ya des
gilets jaunes flamand qui a vu saisir de
tri lancer une plate forme au niveau
national donc tout le monde à pouvoir
aller s'inscrire et voter dessus on va
pouvoir donc la parole à m libre une
effet vraiment pour tout le monde alors
lucas tous métaux minés on le voit dans
cette vidéo on est très loin des
ressorts classiques de la politique je
pense qu'on est con et vraiment c'est
pour ça que moi j'hésite à faire cette
comparaison entre les deux gillet jeune
mouvement 5 étoiles c'est très très
difficile
on peut la seule comparaison qu'on
pourrait imaginer c'est entre le
mouvement 5 étoiles du début 2009 2007
la mobilisation avec les gilles et jean
actuelle ce qu'il ya effectivement des
thématiques
similaire on trouve la critique la
rupture avec la classe politique on
trouve la critique fort aux acteurs
intermédiaires de la société partis
syndicats médias justement on trouve des
critiques aux banques au système
bancaire médias dans le manifesto de ji
légion on trouve de la sortie de l'union
européenne et de l'otan aussi comme 12
ans - le mouvement cinq étoiles de les
forces avec vous et bien les jd je ne
pourrais pas se structurer comme l'a
fait le mouvement 5 étoiles c'est une
belle civilité l'aspect kiki qui est
très différent c'est que on est dans des
contexte très différent parce que à
l'époque en 2009 le mouvement 5 étoiles
était vraiment le mouvement des groupes
tour avec le passé avec la classe
politique actuelle
maintenant en france on est dans une
situation dans un contexte complètement
différent
on a déjà la route tour a déjà eu lieu
entre guillemets en 2006 en 2017 avec
les élections présidentielles c'est à
dire on efface on est dans un contexte
très concurrentiel pour les jets les
jeunes pour un possible partis
politiques des gilets jaunes parce que
si on regarde aussi les thématiques les
sujets des programmes vous me dites on
peut faire la comparaison entre muji
légion et mouvements 5 étoiles l'époque
oui on peut faire aussi on trouve des
points communs entre les gilles et gien
et la france insoumise
le rassemblement national il ya beaucoup
de concurrence pour les jets les jeunes
aujourd'hui à france sur le plan
idéologique il ya quand même ce point
commun c'est de se revendiquer ni de
droite ni de gauche jean arthuis je
pense qu'il y a il ya un contexte qui a
un terreau qui est le même c'est le
sentiment d'être marginalisé de ne pas
être respecté de ne pas être entendus
d'avoir perdu son emploi et de
s'inquiéter de son avenir
c'est une crise de la démocratie
l'élection d' emmanuel macron au mois de
mai était déjà une forme de protestation
c'était une remise en cause du système
parce que ce système ne répond plus à la
tempe système politique aussi classique
c'est un peu ça c'est un schisme
politique doit se remettre en cause les
partis politiques
et aujourd'hui on peut partir
gaillardement en disant on va sortir de
la zone euro
on va sortir de l'europe et puis on se
rend compte que c'est pas si simple
parce que on est dans la mondialisation
et que on peut avoir les meilleures
idées en chine quiz télé ou en gilet
jaune
viendra un moment où le principe de
réalité va devoir être respectée on peut
avoir une démocratie participative
direct à l'échelon local à l'échelon de
la municipalité
mais on voit bien que à l'heure de la
mondialisation il y à des démarches
communes qu'il faut organiser à
l'échelon européen et qu'on ne peut pas
si facilement s'extraire de ces
obligations que nous sommes dans un
monde complexe sans doute faut-il
prendre le temps de mieux définir les
principes selon lesquels nous
travaillons les populistes n'hésite pas
à voir des formulations extrêmement
simple et on voit bien que ce qui nous
affecte aujourd'hui a également affecté
des états unis d'amérique
une section fall c'est ce sont des
populistes l'élection de trump est déjà
une manifestation de crise de la
démocratie
donc comment le mouvement des gilets
jaunes va-t-il évoluer maintenant on
voit bien la difficulté d'arriver à une
formulation claire et unique d'un projet
politique
est ce que vous leur aviez en tant que
membre du mouvement 5 étoiles vous
sentez proche des gilet jaune en france
alors en fait aujourd'hui les mauvaises
5 étoiles regarde avec attention les
mouvements des légions nous avons mis à
disposition de tous les partis
politiques qui l'ont me demander qui ont
besoin d'un en ce moment des démocratie
directe la plateforme rousseau
évidemment bien évidemment les
mouvements que 5 5 étoiles condamne
fortement la l'utilisation de la force
et de la violence mais on regarde avec
attention les mouvements d'un gilet
jaune mais il y a une chose qui est
commune entre les jus légion et les
mouvements que cinq étoiles les besoins
des changements parce qu'aujourd'hui les
citoyens ont besoin de changement la
droite la gauche
les vieux partis politiques ont démontré
des maîtres par capable à soutenir les
citoyennes à
donner des réponses concrètes aux
citoyennes et aujourd'hui les citoyens
la france avec les gilets jaunes
--mouvement que cinq étoiles en italie
ont demandé clairement tu d'avoir un
changement
l'évolution des idées je n'en sais en
tout cas quelque chose qu'on observera
dans les mois qui viennent avant les
élections européennes c'est en tout cas
ainsi que se termine notre débat
aujourd'hui merci à tous les trois d'y
avoir participé merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis retrouvez cette émission en
replay sur nos différents sites lcpan
public sénat et rtbf.be très belle
semaine à tous et à très bientôt
[Musique]